foreign
I don't know this is why I'm afraid of
the ocean this is connected to one of
the oceans right
oh my God oh my God
whoa he's the big boy damn boy he's sick
that's a thick ass mythosaur that is
huge he's like a claw fish
what is that it's like well he's he's
huge it's like the Naboo big things
I didn't think those things went
underwater welcome back to new rock
stars the Mandalorian yeah season three
episode two just happened and the Mythos
are is no longer a myth no my friends it
is a star a true eyesore I would say uh
our minds are blown uh we feel like Boca
time and this moment all of our dreams
are now possible all of our dreams can
come true Jake Barrick
a Mandalorian after show
yeah and we are reacting right now to
Mandalorian season three episode two and
uh we have so many questions hot start
hot start to the season yo I gotta say
this is this season's getting back to
the what it really means to be a
Mandalorian and I can't say enough good
things about that okay yes let's
introduce who we are I'm Eric Voss I'm
here with Tommy Bechtel it's special
guest Hector Navarro
our Wookie Duo has become a Wookie Trio
lick it on me baby sounds good to me
lick it on me I'm ready for it me and
Hector Hector kept coming up behind us
before we start recording saying lick it
on no I said leak it I said Wookie leak
it on Hector's been dming me well they
got me baby for weeks and I didn't know
any better it's not better to say Lika
said I got a fever and the only
prescription Tommy leaking on me the
truth is my secret I'm always leaking oh
crap okay before we uh talk about what
happened in this episode yes let's take
a moment to shout out the best way to
support really are new rockstars network
is to grab one of these Mando inspired
shirts yeah nerd riot dot shop tell me
which one are you wearing I am wearing
the wherever he goes I go and by the way
we should mention this whole collection
is called the way so if you want to get
in the way you got to buy one of these
shirts dressed like this
get this freak out of here why are you
showing me that I'm still in Brandon
Barracks Impressions we want to thank a
few people who bought custom shout outs
with their this is the way merch all
right Howard Scott says well met helmet
grogu Wherever You Wish and Lex Mando
let's talk about what happened on this
episode guys it's bunta Eve I hope you
put out your Ubuntu stockings because
bunta Claus is near I don't think that's
what it is what is the difference
between life day I've got my head
wrapped around life day yes I understand
I've read all those stories I know about
the Wookie celebrating life Dan kashik
what is Boone to Eve well let me just
give you what I know and Eric feel free
to chime in if you know but I think
bunta is a a holiday specific to
Tatooine and of course it clicks it it
kicks off with the Ubuntu Eve classic
Padres and yes that is the canonical
name of that event okay yeah so don't
write in and we get to see a little
glimpse of that the first episode right
as we come in there's some pods that's
pod racing I'm sure of it yeah which is
that's exciting it's gonna be like the
the football game on on Thanksgiving
right right now so it's I like it
there's a sport to honor it I think
they'll just find any excuse to Padres
before but like well it's both
the Festival of the twin Suns we must
Padres there's always a few of those
suns in the sky I don't know we're just
finding excuses to drink really yeah
we've got a rhodian who has a speeder
that has been stripped apart he goes to
pelly motto to get some help belly model
is happy to oblige and why is that
because she and the Jawas have stripped
the thing herself she's selling the man
back his stolen Parts this is such a
George Lucas muscle car 60s era story or
a little plot line very very much we
know George Lucas was obsessed with hot
rods American Graffiti yeah like you had
said before Hector I just love this
moment I thought this was a little
homage to George Lucas a little Easter
egg for Georgie Mando and grogu land in
Pele model shop and they're still
looking for that replacement IG memory
circuit which uh causes pelly to go okay
grandpa so obviously these IG memory
circuits have not been made since the
days of the Empire yeah you know when
they had to make drawings of killed
quite question for both of you yeah does
anybody know the Fate in Canon or
whatever of IG 88 oh the Bounty Hunter
from Empire Strikes Back what happened
to it I don't did it get destroyed
because the first thing I thought was
well the Star Wars galaxy is the tiniest
Galaxy ever created so the one IG unit
that he's gonna find the thing from is
gonna be from IG 88 somewhere right and
then Mando's going to kill ig-88 pull
the thing put it back in the other one
and then we have taika ytt oh it's like
a heart transplant yeah would they have
to reprogram the chip though isn't that
what got damaged and that's why he
defaulted
remember the power of friendship wins
all in stores so ig-11 will remember the
friendship he had with Mandalorian it
was a friendship a driver that was
damaged inside of itself yeah we saw big
hero six yeah exactly Hector you
couldn't be more correct about the Droid
uh thank you for hugging me that felt so
good about the small Universe because
Pali convinces Mando to take r5d4 a
Droid that has been through it all from
self-sabotage
R2D2 convinced r5d4 to blow his uh
inhibitor chip in a new home so that
R2D2 could go with Luke this guy this
Droid this little Droid his inhibitor
wait so you're saying I thought it was a
busted motivator first busted motivator
no it was an inhibitor chip and then he
lost all his inhibitions
okay of course if you trust Wikipedia
I'm powered by fandom which is what when
I read my oral history or read my oral
history written when I written history
of r5d4 yeah R2D2 beeped in r5d4 and
caused him to go
laughs
so there you go the rest is history
Mando says sure it's Boutique we're
getting it for half price that's our
cold open baby that's not even the
episode guess what happens in the
episode we had two Mandalore
and it's not a pretty sight guys I'll be
honest I love it I love that he also
gives grogu a tour right before he's
like okay so before we go here there is
Kyle of it there's Concordia and then
that's friendship Island yeah
but it's like yeah it's kind of like hey
here's the the shitty City and we moved
out to our suburbs so we can have
backyards and just live with people who
look like us like where are the
fireworks that other planet had
fireworks and he's like we don't have
fireworks on Mandalore we have well they
do they just serve mushroom clouds yeah
they're Fusion box airplanes Fusion
bombs which have created a beautiful we
don't know what the timeline was I mean
you know we all looking odd insects
Frozen in Amber but yet this entire
planet is basically Frozen in fusion
bomb green Amber uh which is uh and and
we're all negative about it the air
might be toxic no this is fusion bomb
Erasure the fusion bombs made it
beautiful where are you going to this oh
that's your final yeah that's my thesis
nope so so Amanda sends our five out to
get a to get an air sample on the on the
surface of Mandalore and underneath
maybe yeah go into that crevasse uh and
our and then he's like we can track R5
to grogu on this little about two
seconds and then just like every time a
radar is showing a beeping thing you
know that thing's gonna eventually
disappear and then either Godzilla shows
up right the romulans show up or if you
show a blank radar you know that
something's about to appear like we got
company and that's what happens in
everything else I'm good baby all right
now Mando pressurizes his helmet follows
him into the cave but he's attacked by
alamites hello new friend alert alamites
I've got alamite fever and that is fatal
so alamites these guys are new to Star
Wars yeah this isn't something that
we've seen before were they in Legends
no I mean I looked all I scoured the
internet for any reference to alamite
this is Wookie please Jimmy felt like a
um
these felt like Macquarie Originals yes
Ralph mcquarie Originals to me and I
wonder if Al like if someone's last name
was like alone or something like that
they're like well call them alamites I
don't know anyway the air is safe to
breathe not in this office this office
is still toxic but on the planet in
Mandalore in the air safe to breathe so
rumor number one about Mandalore
debunked a lot of rivers debunked in
this episode the air is safe to breathe
folks yeah so Mando and grogu head into
the Civic Center there is no monster
truck rally which to me means it's not a
true Civics is that uh rumor is that
like a a thing that is explicitly stated
or is it like the rumor is that
Mandalore is cursed so then therefore
somebody extrapolated then oh it's got
to be poisoned from that point I know
when season two told bocaton and
ex-woves and coscares like that place is
toxic he used the term like this okay
okay but it's interesting that there was
a reversal in a before one of this
season he was the one telling Bo that it
wasn't right it wasn't dangerous oh yeah
because as soon as it benefits his life
he's like I'm Gonna Break The Rules it's
all it's all propaganda but this is a
great mirror to our society and how
things work and how different like
Legends and and myths about like this
place don't go there that place is
cursed that's true and and people have
all different reasons why it's cursed to
suit their needs and motivations now
Mando needs to get back there Suddenly
It's Not So cursed anymore wait a minute
are you saying that that the curse
propaganda was like enacted by the
Empire or somebody who wanted to keep
the mandalorians from uniting because
I think it was the armorer I think the
armorer is going to be the big bad of
this season what are you kidding I think
we start with her during the beginning
of the season I think she's gonna be
revealed to me basically a cult leader
one is a Manson one of the words that
John Favreau said that he used to
describe this season was Redemption and
I don't think he was talking about just
Bo Katan because I think she will be
redeemed yeah I think Katie Sackhoff is
so Charming that you're not gonna have
her be the full villain for forever like
let her be somebody who can kind of have
that Arc right but I also think that the
armorer POS Vizsla that entire Clan are
basically going to see
not to put down religion the error of
their ways when they look at the example
of bocatan when they look at the example
of their history and their legacy of the
mandalorians I mean you were bringing up
an amazing point during the live stream
that I watched this morning when that
kid in episode one was doing the oath
when did the meth gator attack Eric when
did it attack meth Gator written by our
friends Lauren Pritchard and her husband
Joe well coming from Florida the meth
gator attacks when you least expect it
to which is at all times it should be
more often the amount of times Navigator
hits
yeah right when he's right before he
said and I will never take off my helmet
which you're right that is see that's
nature that's the first that is the
force and that's what the Jedi call it
it's of course the mandalorians probably
have a different word so I believe the
armorer is going to be a character who
was so strict in her beliefs but she may
see the light she may then go you know
what the the the the cooling Waters of
Lake Minnetonka have proven that
Mandalorian and she will then take off
for him
Arc is going to be for pause I think in
the middle and we'll see and it'll be
Fabrics
Fletcher did all the physical work
all season but I think I think the armor
is so devout in her ways
you think she'll like sacrifice herself
like she'll be like this is the way and
then jump into another meth gator mouth
or something like an elastic well I feel
like people usually die by their own
like but like bad guys usually die by
their own humorous or blade right bad
people they don't have to be guys I
think she's gonna die in that in that
Forge she's gonna get forged into uh
she's gonna slip accidentally
Frozen in basketball this is the way and
then die Dipper and best guard make a
statue put her next to ig-11 anyway they
are safe to breathe like I said to head
into the Civic Center Mando gets
captured by this freaky creep [__] whoa
we have to talk about this yeah I love
this giant it's like a little thing that
we end up seeing it gets down to the
size of like a football the head but
it's like it's alive yeah and it's
powering this like three different mechs
right like it's got the giant one it's
got the little Puma Mac and then it's
got little Krang Mech uh did it remind
anyone of like John Carpenter's The
Thing where the head breaks off of the
body and then grows the spider legs I
was getting uh General Grievous Vibes I
remember when Grievous first appeared he
first appeared in the Genji tardotovsky
animated 2D animated hand-drawn Star
Wars Clone Wars know that yes and I love
those series those micro shorts were so
great and he was a badass and then they
did season two that was leading up to uh
episode three Revenge of the Sith and
they really nerfed them because they're
like oh in episode three he has like a
cough yeah and he's like and then so so
like they made him from this really
scary threat to like we have to have
we'll have Mace Windu crush his heart
and that'll explain how he and now those
shorts aren't even Canon so it doesn't
matter but when he first appeared I
remember like asking like deep Star Wars
fans like what is he and they're like
he's a Droid and I was like I don't know
he's got a weird little no it's the
exact full Droid and then he's not yeah
but he kind of has like Droid like you
know yeah attachment so this is what
that character remind me of what
Wikipedia say is there any names or have
we seen it before I have not I was
unable to identify I have a feeling you
know this season we're gonna have a lot
of Revelations of what these things are
alligator snapping turtle uh get meth
Gators fine I'm fine with meth Gator by
the way see I think the alligator
snapping turtle was like an Egyptian
crocodile
because they they have the mandoa Exodus
passage and I think you know they they
threw the Hebrew slave children to the
crocodiles in the Nile and then Amit is
the Devourer of the Dead as a crocodile
head I think it was connected with that
you know what I love about this show is
that all of that is probably true and
then also in the writer's room or
whatever they're also like and then they
use their jet packs and blow it up like
it's like that plus this show feels like
playing with action figures as we said
gets captured and then I gotta say this
is talk about a father sending his son
off with a lot of trust he goes go to
Boca time I was like yeah no problem let
me ask a few questions how do I talk how
do I fly a ship uh where is Bo Katan
again bogoton is is retrieved but she
sees krogo and she's like I immediately
understand what you need me to do uh
they had a Mandalorian Incredible or on
her ship didn't jarin stuck in a well
it was that was big Lassie Vibes right
although I would never compare grogu to
that bastard dog he knows what he did so
does his grandson I got beef with that
hole by the way
all right you can delete that uh don't
get me started it on Toto that piece of
work so bocatan gets into ship they get
down to back to the surface of Mandalore
the exact same spot coordinates are
plugged in grogan's like no it's right
there once in the Civic Center they are
once again attacked by the alamites
which is where we actually learn their
name and their origin they used to live
kind of in the outskirts of uh of the
city I wonder I'm curious we'll get into
this more later like if their
relationship was always so antagonistic
or maybe that you know because they have
they wear clothing they have tools
they're sentient they're an advanced
culture clearly to some degree I think
they're the Tuscan Raiders the
mandalorians right yeah it does feel
that way so we gotta wait for them to
get redemption in like a later season
let's just I think it's going to be Boba
Fett who just goes in there that adopts
and appropriates their culture and
becomes one of them clean it up on Boba
Fett as I always say yeah so then we get
this great sequence with Boca tan
rescues dinjarin and wheels the dark
saber and we see how she's still locked
into the lore of that because she wields
the dark saber but does not keep it she
gives it back yeah she didn't win it
fairly that's right it's interesting she
seems way more Adept at wielding that
lightsaber yeah
struggled once again I love seeing him
struggle with the dark yeah more than
someone just wheeled in the dark saver
someone
projects everything's too easy for him
you know so I'd like to see him get
stabbed by baseball bats and struggle
with dark Sabers that's the way to do it
exactly I couldn't agree more so then
finally the moment we've been waiting
for Boca tan takes Damon Kroger to the
mines where they find those sweet sweet
Living Waters and a fun commemorative
plaque who doesn't love commemorative
plaques letting you know where you are I
liked it even on Mandalore it's a little
bit like a Prairie museum in Kansas
we're like on this site Abraham Lincoln
gave an address oh that plaque yeah yeah
George Washington Got Tea here did
anybody get Disneyland Vibes I'm like
who wrote that like Walt Disney and the
little archways you go oh no enter here
be they mandalorians or young at heart
Welcome to The Living Waters just ahead
you'll see a pretty big myth
Mando does the old Marx brother this
thing where he takes two steps and then
drops to the bottom of the Living Waters
uh or was pulled down we're we're still
doing such an old reference Tommy that
young people watching you rockstars are
not gonna be like who what where yeah
they're Marx Brothers
New Kids on the Block where are you guys
at you guys know Vanilla Ice call in if
you do Bo rescues him uh and we're still
debating the weight of these uh
Mandalorian armor suits because that jet
pack has room for two I guess they're
shooting on up and on the way we get a
glimpse of a aquatic mythosaur a big one
yeah a big old mythosaur and I do like
Bo's reaction even in a helmet it's like
laughs
foreign
about the mythosaur what what is rookie
leaks what can we learn uh the Mythos
are the sacred beasts to the to the
watch and to all Mandalorian people yeah
uh they were untameable considered
untameable uh apex predators on on the
planet of Mandalore until tarvisla was
able to tame them and ride them and then
those ancient mandalorians following his
stead were able to ride the Mandalore
beasts as mounts trusting them as one
does uh with their horses or a rancors
yes or rancors if you're Boba uh so yeah
it's it's a considered untamable beast
and then you know they're they're like
long gone you know it's many things are
but no one want to stay uh I don't know
how what what is it feeding on like what
what is the ecosystem of the American
Mandalore is it alamites I don't feel
like he could sustain himself on
alamites and they wouldn't go in I don't
know they look like good eating
like that meat Falls right off the bone
slow roasted out the Galaxy's Edge next
year but then but then there's this
important uh kind of Prophecy right to
the Mandalorian people that the ones who
uh foresee a man uh returning mythosar
wait I'm sorry say that again we were
talking earlier about the the myth is
like the the first yeah uh myth sorry to
present himself too yeah that will mean
a rebirth of the Mandalorian people that
means the Renaissance of their culture
they're coming back that is the The
Herald of it's time for Mandalore to get
its Groove Back where's Whoopi Goldberg
we're getting going here guys we're
getting the game so so did din Jaron
also see it I imagine yes or was it was
then like knocked unconscious at the
bottom of the ocean floor I think he was
incapacitated okay so you think this is
for Bo you think Boca tan is going to be
the leader and I think that's why they
include that line earlier of I'll
pressurize my helmet and then after he
realizes is clean he depressurized his
helmet and when he went down there his
helmet was no longer pressurized because
he didn't expect to drop so I think that
rapid descent uh probably knocked him
out he probably went unconscious yeah uh
bocaton lifted him up it just seemed
like he wasn't helping at all yeah yeah
you're right you're right he was gonna
kick your legs a bit Yeah I think she
saw it that was a moment for Bo because
she was the the non-believer at the
beginning of this episode yeah and I
think this was a moment to kind of
Empower her like he won the darksaber
from off Gideon in rightful combat but
it's a sword that it's a responsibility
he doesn't necessarily want I think the
fact that she's still able to wield the
darksaber successfully and see the
mythosar this was a hero moment for Boca
time I think this was an empowering
episode for her and this is like what's
gonna light a spark under her ass to to
challenge him for the Sabers we we
talked about r5d4's motivator yeah but
now the mythosaur is Bo katan's
motivated well this is great guys we've
jumped the gun a little bit here because
that is actually our first question guys
oh yeah who answered it I think we can
explore it a little more
how how's the fat to do a throwback to
an old Wikileaks call how the fet will
seeing the mythosaur motivate Bo katan's
next move now I theorize the last week's
episode yeah that I thought Bo Catan was
playing possum a little bit I thought
she was kind of like eh my people are
all gone you should go lead him I don't
care to kind of make din jar and
underestimate her because eventually
she's gonna still try and get him to get
that sword this episode kind of made it
seem like no she might actually really
be that nihilistic yes up until the
point where she saw the mythosaur we
know the only way she truly believes she
can earn that dark saber back is to
defeat Doom Jared in combat right he
can't hand it over to her he has to she
has to believe in her mind at least that
he's trying to win right so do we think
that's coming will she attack him
unawares is she gonna attack him and put
his life in danger and if that happens
won't grogu just kind of like
her
I think yeah it's hard for me to imagine
what bocaton or uh or did Jordan's
future will be because I think the point
of The Exodus
um line in episode one is to paint these
figures as the uh the Hebrews leaving
Egypt wandering in the desert trying to
find the promised land and the thing
about that that wandering is that Moses
didn't survive to make it into the
promised land whoa and and the there's
various interpretations over why he
didn't make it but uh I always grew up
with the teaching that because it's like
a generational thing that we have to
forgive our uh the prior generation of
their sins of their imperfections and
that every successive generation has to
get morally better and work our way
towards better moral Purity and that
Moses as someone who was there during
the plagues of Egypt was not pure of
heart enough to see that promised land
and so Joshua LED uh the Hebrews into
the promised land and I think grogu
represent represents to Joshua even
though grogu is a Moses figure a bastard
in a basket I know I know it's not
perfect doesn't line up perfectly but I
think grogu is the next Generation so I
don't think it is the Moses Dennis the
Moses who you know will will definitely
lead at some point I just don't know how
bocaton fits into it because she's also
she's had too much of a mixed track
record I think she's like it's the
Mandalorian Jedi and I think grogu is
the tarvis uh reincarnate well is is is
Boca tan is she like the Moses in this
situation she could be the Moses
what about the Ramses could she be the
Ramses oh the yeah the the bad one I
mean who would be the mop Gideon is he
the Ramses that's what's so messy about
this is because like yes yes the the
mandalorians are a diasporatic group of
people they're Wanderers uh they were
forced to leave but it's You could argue
they were cursed in a way by their own
Folly if it depends on who you ask and
you know the Israelites or they were in
Israelites yeah but the Hebrews were
slave were enslaved by the Egyptians so
it's not like they it's not like they
brought about their own downfall right
but bottom line you're saying dinar is
not going to survive this season Eric
Boss says I think he'll survive it I
just don't think he will be by the end
of the series
and we already know favorite's got
season four right is writing it right
like he said it's it's either in process
or finished yeah but didn't he also say
like he doesn't really have an end game
in mind for this show he's just gonna
let it keep going let's get into that is
he being truthful or is he just kind of
playing his cards a little close to the
vest yeah yeah I mean I'm fine with
either you know what but it's a mystery
that we're all gonna have to sleep on
and speaking of sleep on well we can't
all visit the Living Waters of Mandalore
to Kira cure what else we can get a good
night's sleep and here at new rockstars
we love our sleepy time with Helix and
we have for many many years now Helix
makes premium mattresses and betting
that are customized to fit your needs
and conveniently shipped to your door
that's great which Helix mattress is
right for you don't worry about it Helix
makes a sleep quiz that matches your
unique body type and sleep preferences
the perfect mattress for you based on
your preferences and sleep positions and
firmness preferences they have something
for everyone's unique taste and if you
sleep with a partner you know I do yeah
you can take the Sleep quiz together and
find something that's perfect compromise
for both of you not for me I'm a
dictator in the bed no anytime Eric you
and I both have Helix mattresses that we
enjoy very much do you have a helix
mattress no but I'm gonna get one well
you know what stick with this show long
enough we're gonna make one happen for
you yay now I love my Helix mattress I
sleep like an angel yeah and I live like
a devil so it's good for me how's your
lumbar surprise your back I gotta be
honest my lumbar never been stronger oh
God my kidneys destroyed the best part
about all of this is that Helix delivers
a mattress straight to your door folks
plus Helix has a 100 night sleep trial
and if you don't know after 100 Hawk
shoes whether or not that mattress is
right for you I'll tell you what they'll
give you a full refund and you got to be
a little more decisive in your life
Helix mattress has a 10 year warranty
that's a decade that's two and a half
presidential terms that's two Summer
Games two Winter Games and either a
summer or winter games depending on when
you buy it that's a whole DC reboot
right that's true entire DC Universe
planned out he looks like I said
they have a 10-year warranty they offer
financing options and flexible payment
plans so great night's sleep is never
far away I love my Helix baby and I
think you would too wow look at this oh
my God
and if you're looking for a new bed
check out Helix you can click the link
below or go to helixsleep.com break room
to get 20 off your Helix mattress plus
two free pillows that's helixsleep.com
break room we also want to thank factor
for sponsoring this episode of the break
room presents Wikileaks power up for
Springtime with Factor America's number
one ready to eat meal kid kit nutritious
Chef prepared meals delivered straight
to your door leaving you time and energy
to tackle everything on your to-do list
look and feel your best in time for
warmer weather with calorie smart meals
around 550 calories or less that's
incredible too busy to cook well with
Factor skip the trip to the grocery
store skip the chop and skip the prep
and skip the cleaning up two factors
fresh never frozen meals are already
just wow wow factors are factors fresh
never frozen meals already in just two
minutes so all you got to do is heat and
enjoy Factor has delicious flavor packed
meals to help you live the fullest
choose from keto vegan and veggie
calorie smart and Protein Plus options
on the menu each week prepared by chefs
and approved by dietitians each meal has
all the ingredients you need to feel
satisfied all day long with 34 Chef
prepared dietitian approved weekly
options there's always something new to
try enjoy meals any time of day with
breakfast options like egg bites
smoothies and more plus replenish your
snack Supply with an assortment of 45
add-ons get factor and enjoy clean
eating without the hassle simply choose
your meals enjoy fresh flavor pack meals
delivered right to your door ready in
just two minutes no prep no mess Let me
say something real quick here if you
don't mind I want to give a personal
anecdote about this me and my two of my
buddies Chris and Mike Chris's last name
is actually Michael so it's Chris
Michael Mike and Michael uh we're doing
hot boy summer training and we're using
factor to help us get in shape hot boy
summer training we got three months till
summer roughly maybe a little more and
we're gonna get those Beach bods and by
the way Beach Bud doesn't mean you have
zero body fat Beach Bodies whatever body
you have as long as you throw on some
sand okay speak on it all bodies are
fine no need to comment on mine in these
YouTube comments guys I know what I look
like it's fine Eric how can we get these
sweet sweet Factory meals well all you
got to do is head on over to
factormeals.com break room 50 and use a
code break room 50 to get 50 off your
first box it's code break room 50 at
factormeals.com break room 50 to get 50
off your first box holy cow all right
guys that's awesome let's get back into
this okay Bo Katan mentions the Jedis
and mandalorians I'm sorry Jedi and
mandalorians have worked together in the
past fought side by side
is there a chance in both you guys you
guys can say maybe I'm a little out of
my mind here could we see a live-action
Clone Wars flashback in this series
Tommy what happened at the end of season
two of this show
what happened who arrived who showed up
okay I'm gonna have to remember Luke
Skywalker that's right yes played by
whom Mark Hamill yeah pretty much I mean
and other technology and all the
Artistry and that's all amazing but all
together the package was Mark Hamill was
on some kind of payroll right yeah
that's true who did they just get on the
payroll to produce the show called
Obi-Wan Kenobi you and McGregor
I mean yeah McGregor he is right there
Hayden Christensen that's what I'm
seeing he's into it he likes being in
Star Wars again yeah what's what's
likelier that we see an Obi-Wan Force
ghost talking to grogu or we see a d
aged uh Ewan McGregor to the Clone Wars
just give a nice haircut and clean shave
the guy let me let me throw let me throw
it let me throw this your way Eric what
about if we got not just an Obi-Wan
Kenobi da June McGregor but there was an
actor hired to play Duchess sateen I
think that's the way right that's the
way to go because you I mean you could
even just do they're both girls you know
braiding each other's hair or something
like that right right in these same
holes if these if these uh sharply
angled walls could talk like a flashback
to bocatan's Childhood and they're both
like the sisters from Frozen yeah you
could do that but but do you want to
build a snowman yeah no
no come on SO team but to have you and
McGregor actually act opposite an actor
who's portraying a character that in the
Clone Wars and in the Star Wars story
was a very significant relationship to
one another that could also feed into
the themes of like maybe the
mandalorian's religion isn't right about
everything the way the Jedi wasn't right
about uh being like you can't have
attachments it's like even Obi-Wan had
some kind of a romantic feelings and you
know was struggling with that attachment
I think everyone caught feelings I think
he did I think we're in speaking in the
Force ghost conversation I think we're
more likely to see a name in my mind
bigger than Luke Skywalker himself
bigger than Obi-Wan Kenobi what do you
think of when you think of Star Wars
what character what name what is grogu's
nickname
I think we're going to see a force ghost
Frank Oz voiced puppet of Yoda Yoda oh
my God conversing with grogu that's got
to happen it's gonna that's that's the
only thing I can think of that could
like top the season two reveal of not
placoon but Luke Skywalker wow
wow didn't mean for this to sound
sarcastic Order 66 is we're gonna get to
it at some point I don't know what
episode though it's gonna trigger that
memory right because right now we aren't
concerning ourselves with the Jedi
history at all are you about to say what
I think you're about to say
CAD Bane no no rule of three that's good
that Yoda saved grogu oh he could have
he was still getting off a Dagobah
though at the moment depends how much
time he needed to get from Diego but
didn't he go fight uh Palpatine in the
Senate he or is that um that's that came
after yeah so he met up with Obi-Wan
they went to the Jedi Temple when they
got to Coruscant first they reviewed the
security tapes oh and then from the
murderer Obi-Wan went to Mustafar to
fight Anakin and then
I think Yoda knew about grogu yeah had
to have had to have I think he had to
have known wow that'd be great well I
would love to see a forest ghost uh Yoda
I would lose my mind I would lose it I'd
simply lose it all right do we think din
Jaron completed his Redemption is he now
bathed in the waters
great questions Tommy these are
fantastic questions thank you well you
know I I wanted you guys to be impressed
with me wait but is this the real the
act of bathing in the water and that's
why the armor was like yeah sure go this
way sounds good she knows that like this
sucker doesn't know that we're giving a
Southern Baptist baptism we're gonna
dunk you all the way and practically
drown you and then if you survive that
sure okay you've heard you've earned a
spot back sure does she know that the
mythosar is down there no one or maybe
she's like feed the mythosar yeah yeah
maybe she's like he'll just get eaten by
the myth inside wait a minute Eric
you're just really on this like the
armor is the bad guy
because it's so tough because the armor
at the performance what's the name of
the actor that plays the armor again
she's fantastic oh the at the
performance level the reason I'm
bringing it up is this she has such a
cool air about herself right she has
kind of like an above it all the voice
is fantastic the body language so when
Mando is giving her information that is
like really like contradictory to what
she knows to be true but he's giving her
enough info that it's like but if I do
this I'm good right she has no choice
but to go this is the way and the way
she says it could be very cool and
calculated but it also could be like
you're correct and I'm going to give you
that but I'm not going to be excited
about it like it's it's that kind of
performance so she did feel like she was
both caught in kind of a legal loop
exactly exactly but I think that there
was something more to it I think she's
just like Mr Incredible's boss in the
incredible legally I'm supposed to say
Yes we help people what about our people
Bob this is an incredible moment for me
I'm getting a psychic blast Emily
swallow is the name of it whoa who
psychic plastic Jean Gray from the X-Men
arcade I think it was baby Yoda
[Music]
he's awesome I got a question for you
guys
um uh is is Baby You're Gonna gonna
speak this season
he did say Pele right and he's getting
like vocalizing things I mean she read
it as pilly I think it was like yeah
it's getting there and there was a
moment where it sounded like he said in
response to something din said that he
said like okay and he said yeah and it
was the cutest thing ever and I wanted
to punch my screen and eat a baby it was
so cute so he said I want his first
words to be dad oh my gosh you know I
want it to be dead
oh here's the other question is he gonna
talk like Yoda or like yaddle oh because
are you I'm all about the yaddle gang
yaddle gang rise up yaddle voiced by
Bryce Dallas Howard speaks what we would
consider normally which I think is the
best thing to be revealed in Star Wars
in years
because yo like Yoda speaking the way he
does still being the smallest still
being the most powerful Jedi ever is
this great like it's so such a leap but
I'm like maybe if there were young kids
watching Star Wars that have like
trouble with speaking
I'm like here you have Yoda a character
who's literally an example of like it
doesn't matter like the way he
communicates is so cool and unique and
funny but not what we consider normal
here's yaddle it just sounds like Bryce
Alice Howard now here's an even further
uh thing we know so little about this
race of aliens they don't even have a
name right what is the name what if it's
their second language what if English or
whatever is the second language and
that's why yato is way better at
learning it and Yoda is speaking it in a
fragmented misplaced words because he
doesn't he was homeschooled yeah
or like yaddle grew up in the Star Wars
Galaxy in Coruscant like from a younger
age and Yoda's like I didn't meet
anybody until I was about 400. is there
any I grew up in the Galaxy South is
there any answer to what the name of
Yoda and yaro's species is that is going
to be satisfying they're going to be
like it's called Haru
but here's the thing how much did they
Workshop baby Yoda's name they had to
have we didn't get it until season two
right yeah or was it season one no
season two yeah
I don't know about y'all but like we
heard I saw people on the internet
saying yodito you know all of these
great nicknames speaking of baby Yoda
did grogu disappoint you were you like
yeah that's now I'm like used to it now
you know what I think it just took a
little time to get used to because of
the baby Yoda phenomenon so do you think
that when we learned that Yoda is a
member of the hahoos
we're gonna be like okay
you know what I I I can't
do that
it was so stupid please don't please
don't make hardwood Trend
fabro's like perfect there it is all
right I think we're in post-production
on the last episode and we're just gonna
slip that in there I think our Naboo N1
Cruisers brought out of gas here why
don't we land this bird yeah land this
bird right on their own way I think well
comment down below what your favorite
part of this episode what you think that
the mythosar moment really means with uh
with Boca time is she is she activated
now uh also what's the Armor's role in
all this did we actually hear grogu talk
and what do you think his first name
where it's going to be comment that
stuff rather than other stupid [__]
yeah but uh in the meantime we want to
thank our host for joining us our my
Easter egg breakdown this episode's
gonna be coming out very soon on this
channel next on this channel in between
like four other videos about other
random nonsense but in the meantime
follow Hector at Hector it's funny
follow Tommy at Tommy Beck told you can
follow me at eavos be sure to subscribe
to our new channel the Deep dive and
don't forget to go to nerd riot.shop and
get your hands on this great great merch
it's the best way to support us here at
new rockstars thank you all for watching
Eric I want to do a new thing because
Hector's here okay
one two three
[Music]